A few months ago, I got a message
from someone in Slovenia,
telling me about the Cicka,
a very strange and
very sketchy-looking
manual cable car across
the river Sava.
And I immediately wanted to
visit and film it.
The problem is,
it's badly documented,
and what there is,
isn't in English.
So I hired a local production team,
who very quickly told me:
it's been closed.
Like most of the manual cable cars
in this part of the world,
it wasn't being maintained,
and it was becoming unsafe.
Fixing it up to modern standards
or replacing it
would be far too expensive
just so a few hikers can use it.
But one of the perks of
having local producers
is that they can find things
that I really can't.
Because not only did they
find a different cable car,
one of the last still-working ones,
with a completely different
and even sketchier design...
they found the man who still
maintains it to this day.
[IN SLOVENIAN:]
Safety here,
like the sign says,
is on your own
responsibility.
This type of cable car goes back
to the first world war.
The mountains here were part
of the frontline,
and cable cars like this were
installed as makeshift bridges.
But this one's from the 1950s,
built after an old bridge
put up by the Italian army
got washed out by a flood.
And I know, this looks sketchy.
It sounds sketchy!
It squeaks, it bounces,
it sways.
But now I'm standing here,
it feels solid.
I have no worries about this.
Except:
if I draw attention here, could the
government suddenly decide
"well, actually, this is against
regulations" and step in?
Or could some local kids
decide to visit,
and play around and break it, or
vandalise it? Or maybe get hurt?
I've got a duty of care
to the places I visit.
And this is something that the locals
are clearly very proud of.
A couple of them used it while
we've been filming!
Most of the manual cable cars
are gone now,
and as far as I can tell,
there's no definitive list
of those that remain.
One day, they'll be history...
but then, one day,
so will everything.